question of the day like how do you get
it all done with the theme of the
magazine how do we do it you're running
an Empire you have 145 television shows
right you're a father like you're You're
Not Your Food Network show Tournament of
Champions back for a fourth season
obsessed with that show
it is I mean you got to come see it and
your charity
um the Guy Fieri Foundation how do you
do that how do you do it well my
Foundation is a lot about uh First
Responders active military veterans so
we do programs father is a veteran my
dad said yeah my dad was in uh
submarines during Vietnam so having a
chance to cook for the military and
participate with First Responders and
just shed a little bit of what I can do
I can cook and I can gather people and
that can that comfort of food as you
know so well uh sometimes is that hug
and that pat on the back that people
need okay okay I'm learning I'm learning
now like complete pivot will you play a
game with us guy
[Applause]
I know that you both have big palettes
so I want to test your Savor the flavor
I want you if you can really tell me
what you're tasting
[Applause]
Savor the flavor correctly the audience
is going to go home with some awesome
prizes okay it wouldn't be a special
true magazine episode without giveaways
from my little yellow book
you could go home with a few of my
favorite products featured in the issue
take a look at what those are first up
you could go home with the phenomenal
Aura ring I'm wearing mine right now it
tracks heart rate steps activity sleep
the phenomenal Aura ring then you could
also go home with my no drippy sippy a
cut that I designed to go with you
wherever you go from our beautiful line
and when you turn it upside down you'll
understand why we named it the no drippy
sippy and last but not least Stripes is
a wellness brand founded by the
phenomenal Naomi Watts that inspires
change confidence helps women navigate
the changes of menopause and you could
go home with a 300 gift voucher from
stripes
so what do we got to do here's the game
plan okay
you're blindfold you're on okay ready
got it um I have three taste tests here
they're gonna take place I'm gonna pull
this clutch okay here we go hang on hang
on there you go okay you're gonna put
this in here yeah you don't have to do a
ton oh wait there you go wow very here
you go is it sunflower butter almond
butter it's not peanut butter almond
butter wait it's almond butter oh my God
[Applause]
now the next one yeah I hope you don't
mind things that are live and raw
that's gonna be okay we're gonna still
be friends right live in okay let's say
let's take a look right here okay there
we go now this is this is really it's
gonna be a bit crunchy and just work
right through it okay okay there you go
okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's a waffle
all right that is one thick waffle too
thank you now this this one is weird
let's take a look at what this last one
is okay
right here's your spoon
[Applause]
do I eat it
just so you know I didn't pick it
disgusting
this is and this is I'm so sad that I
know what this is but I really think
it's like a cheese spread or something
like that right you got it right it's
cheese
[Applause]
oh my God
exactly which means
audience is going home with all three
prizes
the Tournament of Champions are Sunday
at 8pm on Food Network and when we come
back an easy recipe you can make with
some spring vegetables with my culinary
best Andrew career Pilar Valdez Guy
Fieri let this be the beginning
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign